what's up people of the internet this is
dr john dolone with ramsey network
today we are talking about setting up
relationships
to fail deciding i think i'm going to
make this thing suck before it even
starts i'm answering your emails from
ask john
at ramseysolutions.com and here's the
email that came in that we're talking
about today
dear dr d what's up what's up i'm having
trouble emotionally accepting my
soon-to-be
sister-in-law she met my husband's
brother and they moved very quickly in
their relationship
and now are expecting a baby i didn't
really get a good chance to get to know
her
but now that she'll be part of the
family permanently i find it hard to be
excited
or want to build a relationship with her
i've noticed she has a pretty strong
personality that doesn't
gel with mine she's also very short with
my brother-in-law which doesn't help the
way i feel about her
we're cordial enough but i feel like
every time i
try to reach out to her to strengthen
her relationships she seems to be not
interested
i'm not sure if my feelings are coming
from a place of jealousy or what
in a perfect world i would love a
healthy relationship with her
but should i just let it go and accept
our relationship for what it is
how do i get over this anxiety of seeing
her
love susan it's not susan and she didn't
say love
i just felt like i needed to be loved in
this moment
i'm trying not to go off like a
hurricane so
susan which is a pseudonym is not a real
name here's the deal
you got two choices okay i'm gonna paint
them for you
it's gonna be exciting get out your pen
and paper okay number one
you can choose to be a grown-up or
number two
drum roll you can choose to act like a
kindergartner
that's it that's you get to choose it's
so good man susan this is your big
moment
kindergartner grown-up so i'm not trying
to be a jerk but those are really the
two options
you can act like a child or you can act
like a grown-up
that's it right you say here we are
cordial enough with each other but i
feel like every
time i try to reach out to strengthen
our relationship she seems to not be
interested here's the deal
relationships aren't car engines to be
worked on
they're not relationships are two people
connecting
relationships are silly jokes at
thanksgiving relationships are
uncomfortable relationships are weird
they're obnoxious relationships are
sitting by somebody
who you are now bound with because
you're gonna have a new niece and nephew
and you get to decide whether you're
going to make those situations
uncomfortable
or if you're going to roll with the flow
if you're going to choose to laugh
you're going to choose messiness over
perfection
you get to paint the picture of what
that's going to look like you say in a
perfect world i would love a healthy
relationship with her but should i just
let it go and accept our relationship
for what it is
no no that's what a kid does
kid just picks up their ball and goes
home you choose
to connect to be kind
to send over old kid clothes that you
don't need anymore when the baby's born
to text and say hey i'm praying for you
i'm thinking about you
you send over the baskets if she rolls
her eyes at you you move on
because the only thing you can control
is your thoughts and your actions
you can choose to not be frustrated you
can choose to be joyful you can choose
to laugh
or you can choose to be frustrated and
angry and for the sake of your family
for the sake of your husband for the
sake of
your new niece or nephew and for the
sake of your new
sister-in-law choose joy choose laughter
unless somebody's making you not safe
unless somebody
is making you uncomfortable
choose joy so dr john deloney with
ramsey network do the follows the
internets the buttons and all of it
rock on to the break of dawn be nice to
each other and be a little bit more kind
talk to you soon